[Music]
john's in chattanooga hey john welcome
to the ramsay show how can christy and i
help
hey dave good
thank you for taking my call how you
guys doing great man what's up
so i just recently bought a primary
residence um i've been kind of doing an
investing bit myself about a year now so
far so good you know been great
i've been using the same home inspector
he's been very thorough he's always been
very helpful and informative whenever i
go with him showing me this or you know
teach me more here and there
so this house uh everything was good and
everything so
day one when i first you know finally
closed and we moved in
day one i knew there was something wrong
with the hvac system
and you know i was reaching out to the
realtor just to be like you know hey
did we hear anything was there any i
mean i know despite sellers disclosure
but um
so
i actually had a internet guys what
found the problem and then i've had
different ac companies come in
and they were telling me that you know
the words i used to describe the
oversight of the duct work was uh
catastrophic was he blindfolded did he
even go underneath the house
and you know
to the point of
each quote that i got to even fix the
hvac system is a pretty significant cost
how much um
well i
understand there's different efficient
working and like repairing what needs to
be done
but we're talking maybe eight to ten
thousand on the good side not including
the insulation issues that that he
missed eight to ten thousand dollars
worth of duct work that was not plugged
in and not done right
uh just in ruins and just how many how
many different estimates have you gotten
estimates yeah for fixing the ductwork
uh
three estimates for the ductwork and i
had two for the insulation all kind of
be in the
climate control issue insulation of the
house or the installation of the
ductwork
insulation of the house okay how much
for the ductwork
does work looking about three or four
thousand okay and to that point you want
to spend five thousand dollars on
insulation on your house how big a house
is this
no no no not in insulation that's just
for the ductwork the insulation was
about 2500.
that's not eight thousand
three and two is five
three and two is five the with the
different ac companies and they all
remarkably said the same thing
the unit's too small for the house but
because the house is originally
made as a barn and been added to it so
the floor levels are
different as far as like underneath the
house okay do you think this guy was
smoking dope or do you think he
intentionally ripped you off or do you
think he just made an honest mistake
out of referrals and just kind of
networking i understand he's still kind
of feeling this way so he could be a
little more green i couldn't presume to
say did you bring this problem to him
i did what did he say
uh
initially it was great to hear that he
was you know willing to own up very well
could have overlooked and i was like
that's awesome but you know going to the
quote you know it's kind of like well
everything was working good you know at
time of the inspection and
so on and so forth but
you know 10 days after living there you
know the closet right next to hvac
system was consumed with mold growing
into the bedroom right next to it from
the you know humidity in there
uh he's just keep kind of splitting
hairs a little bit it seems and he's
more like i'm more than happy to consult
and you know do all this and that but
definitely it's trying to stay away from
you know as far as lending a hand in the
financial repairs
appliances for repairs i kind of smell
that you're heating and air guys trying
to make a sale
i might be wrong
but i think he's added some drama to
this
you bought a barn with an air
conditioner on it
i might be wrong i think i'd tread
carefully here
i think your feelings are hurt i tread
careful we were talking with john in
chattanooga he bought a a a barn that
has converted to a home the unit and
it's been added onto the heating air
unit is too small the ductwork was not
connected there was mold and there was a
lack of insulation his home inspector
seemed to have missed this his heat and
air guy asked if the guy was blindfolded
when he did the home inspection
um and so
uh okay john here's what's bothering me
in this in this story are you with me
still okay here's what's bothering me
yeah uh your heating and air guy
uh who stands to benefit from getting
this job
is
blowing this up
and really running down the other guy
the other trade
if the only way i can get work is to run
down the other guy
and i can increase the size of my ticket
i no longer trust
his voice his voice is bothering me in
this story
is that fair entirely okay entirely yeah
and you had a guy that prior to this you
trusted
now have you been under there and looked
at this stuff
yes i have and i know honestly i'm not
an ac guy but i'm not either but
apparently if he wasn't blindfolded he
could have told the according to this
other guy he could have told it wasn't
connected right
yeah i mean rooms of the house not being
connected whatsoever
how many rooms
uh three rooms
okay used to be more but it was opened
up since it's been uh there for so long
okay
so um
i've got a question so
let's say that he did totally screw up
is there any liability it would depend
on what your contract says with your
home inspector
as to how much liability he has limited
i mean and it sounds like he's not a big
time home inspector some of them
actually carry insurance for arizona
missions
that cover the recovery if they miss
something so i would investigate those
two things that's a good question
is what does the actual agreement state
that he's liable for in the event he
misses something like this
uh also
find out if he has insurance to cover it
now past that let's get practical
this guy's a small timer he's got he
doesn't have three or four thousand
dollars to give you
of course even if he wanted to
i mean i don't think you're gonna i
don't think you're gonna get any money
out of it huh
well yeah of course i don't really want
any money out of him per se but we did
speak in regards to you know what
contingency could there be if there was
oversight you know that on his end he
does have insurance to cover it and you
know of course an inspection of
inspection of that time
i don't mind to cover you know
insulation and just uh everything else i
need to take care of but just inside of
it being an oversight considerable
oversight
i'm just curious of your guys thoughts
so i just go ahead and eat it and just
pay for it myself yeah i mean if you can
get an insurance a check out of his
insurance guys i i would if you really
believe he had an oversight
um
because i but i don't think this guy is
going to give you any money because i
don't think he has any money
and i think it's probably the last time
you're going to use him as an inspector
right
yeah that's both those statements are
fair yeah i um but i i'd get the
insurance money out of him if i could
because it sounds like he did miss it if
this if you can get it i i don't know
how complicated it is i've never filed a
claim on something like that
so um i don't know what it is but i also
am a little bit disturbed i think your
heat and air guys overstating this and
adding some drama trying to make a sale
my guess is you've done some rehabs that
you probably can get a a good sub in
there and uh you know get some
bad insulation bat
insulation not bad
and uh get the thing in you know
it sounds like some flex duct run to
those other rooms if the and you're
probably gonna have to upgrade your unit
at some point it's not gonna carry the
whole thing
uh so you know you're gonna lose on this
transaction you're gonna eat some of it
um
and
you know that's i don't know i don't
know a way around that in this situation
because here's the thing i've figured
out and chrissy this is a good principle
for business in general
it's so frustrating when somebody
doesn't do their job
but when they're broke
the contract you signed with them
actually means almost nothing because
they're they're only going to abide by
the contract to the extent they have the
resources to abide by the contract but
they can they can't they don't
physically have the money yeah and so
even if the guy went yep my bad yeah um
he's got you know if he says my bad and
i got he's got a hundred thousand
dollars in a bank account write you a
check that's good but that's not
normally the case in something like this
contracts don't make bad deals good
contracts don't make bad people good
contracts don't make incompetent people
competent and so never sign a contract
and this is not what he was doing by the
way i'm not picking on john but never
sign a contract because i've done this
and i would go and then the whole thing
would blow up and i kind of knew it was
a bad deal but i signed a contract and
then i say the dumbest statement here's
what i would say and some of you have
said this
but i have a contract
as if it had magical powers yeah to make
the incompetent competent the crooked
straight yeah
it doesn't contracts don't have magical
powers just clarify what two good
capable people were going to do that
they do they they have communication
tool for doing what they say they're
going to do that's all a contract does
yeah it's a false sense of security if
you think it's going to
fill a gap that can't be filled by a
contract by a piece of paper yeah
or you get the wonderful opportunity
going to court
to try to you know and then you're just
throwing good money after bad and i've
done that and i probably will have to do
that again in business sometimes i have
to go before the judge and go this
bozo's doing this and i can't get him to
stop and yeah you know and so you gotta
you gotta do it but
she's it's a it's a no it's no win
because it does just cost you money when
people wins the lawyers yeah but well
going back to the heat and air guy you
make a good point too because i was
thinking about this when you were
talking about him and maybe maybe a
layer of drama there of exaggerating and
the whole blindfold comment when you
exaggerate
what's going on even if there are
oversights and issues you lose
credibility when you act in this
exaggerating drum dramatic state and so
wait a minute that's my job
wait a minute this is what we do for a
living
the truth is a suggestion i like to add
a little flare uh but no it's like so so
some people in sales are trying to you
know get a sale they exaggerate so much
that they make the person scared it's
this fear tactic yeah and a scared
person even that it doesn't lead to good
deals it doesn't lead to good decisions
so so even if the guy had some some
valid points the drama takes away the
credibility of of him as a as the person
you want to go to i don't want to go to
him even if he's right i want to go to
someone that seems more credible yeah
and they go gosh this is a horrible
situation how can i help you solve your
problem that's exactly right that says
you know what he overlooked it he may
have been new he just just a more common
sense level-headed approach to assessing
the situation versus this dramatic scene
yeah yeah john i i'm afraid you're
eating a lot of this my friend all of
that to say that